[Music]  this is the gowdy sapphire tarantula  also known as the post litheria  metallica  their exotic blue color comes from tiny  hairs that line their bodies making the  goudi sapphire one of the most beautiful  species of tarantula in the world  the gouti sapphire tarantula lives in  the forests of east gowdy india hence  their name they are very quick and can  defend themselves if they feel  threatened  they are extremely venomous one bite  from them can pack a huge punch causing  humans excruciating pain that can last  over a week  the gowdy sapphire tarantula is  classified as critically endangered  because they only live in a single small  area which is now being harvested for  firewood leading to the loss of their  only habitat  this is the gowdy sapphire tarantula  [Music]  you